all right they say the number seven is
lucky well it sure was for pro golfer
Amy Olson this year she played in the
U.S women's open for the seventh time
during the seventh month of the year
while seven months pregnant
now the Pregnant part is what caught a
lot of media attention including from
the global golf Post in an interview
with reporter Steve Eubank she said the
irony is not lost on me that one year
ago when Roe versus Wade was overturned
women from around the world and even on
tour were outraged now a year later
people are celebrating that I'm going to
be playing a major championship with an
unborn child that they recognize as a
life zing
wow a refreshingly Frank comment
apparently made staff at the global Gulf
post go ballistic and the piece was
pulled stunning the reporter who quit on
the spot
I think this confirms what a lot of us
have been thinking all along if this was
just a story about a golf publication
not running a story we wouldn't be
talking right now but I think it
confirms the belief that everyone has
that in when it comes to Christian
beliefs the media has their fingers on
the scale
and according to that reporter the
Intrepid journalists at USA Today golf
week proceeded to kill the story as well
joining us now is the subject of that
profile Amy Olson professional golfer on
the LPGA Amy did you expect this sort of
reaction I loved your comment it was
awesome
I certainly didn't expect this much
media attention again I didn't expect as
much media attention playing in the US
Open while pregnant
um and I was just so thrilled that
everyone wanted to celebrate life life
is such a huge
um it is just such a huge deal and to
have people celebrate it and recognize
it as valuable and important no matter
what stage is really I mean it renewed
my faith in society well you got a lot
of great attention but the fact that the
golf journalism world is so so shocked
that not everybody agrees on the issue
of Roe versus Wade they're so they're
absolutely shocked by I don't know where
they've been for the past 50 years but
they were so shocked that they had to
pull the story imagine if you were you
know a golfer that you know came out as
bisexual you'd be you know celebrated
it'll be all sorts of you know Awards
you'd be given but you know in this case
no they don't want to hear the story
well I think that's the point is that
you know the news media is supposed to
report news and anything that is going
to Garner the public attention that's
generally what they try to put out but
apparently that's only the case if you
have a certain opinion and so the fact
that my opinion was censored whether it
was because I'm a Christian or
conservative that was really unfortunate
have you felt in any way ostracized by
your fellow tour members or the players
on the tour because of this have you
felt any of that
no honestly I've I've either received
silence or full support and I so
appreciate that good I think that you
know when you have relationship with
people you can discuss these issues even
if you disagree and have respectful
dialogue that's what I want to get back
to is dialogue and making sure that all
opinions are heard the only way you ever
figure out if you're wrong about it
opinion is by having conversations with
people who disagree with you and so
that's why freedom of speech is so
fundamental to a functioning Society
well nothing you said was wrong I mean
there's just no debate about what you
said what you said is just a fact and I
know you're due and you're expecting for
next month correct
yes that's correct when's the next when
you're going to get back on the golf
course after you have the baby that's
the question all the fans want to know
Amy
I know I'm just looking forward to being
a mom I want to adjust to that and then
we'll make a decision going forward well
I have a feeling your son or daughter is
going to be a golfer that's my sense Amy
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else